So, let's unpack a little bit about what you said Michael. You,
you're exactly right in everything that you said and we can sort of
write down these things I think more generally be simply noting a few
of the pluses and the minuses, the pros and the cons. So in
the filtering case one of the things that you, you didn't say explicity
but I think was built into what you said. Is a question of
speed, so filtering is faster than wrapping because you don't have to worry
about what the learner wants, you don't have to worry about paying the
cost of what the learner is going to do. You can basically just
apply any fast algorithm you might imagine that takes a look at the
features and does some sort of filtering. It is of course, as we
pointed out before an exponential problem but you can do some kind of
an approximation here and you can make a. Basically arbitrarily as fast as
you want it to be. Which I think is what you were thinking
about originally when we started the quiz. So you do get speed and
the price that you're paying for that speed it that you tend to look
at the features in isolation. So what do I mean by that.
Well you may look at a feature and say this feature is
unimportant. For whatever reason. But maybe that feature is important if you
combined it with another feature. Say maybe we're in a kind of of parity
problem again. And so some feature might look unimportant but actually, in
fact, it is important. And the only way you're going to get the kind
of speed up that you need is typically by looking at features
in isolation. Either adding them or removing them and of course, the reason
it gets this speed, is that it ignores the
learning problem itself. At least the learner itself, if not
the learning problem. Now, in contrast wrapping actually takes into
account, model bias, it takes into account whatever the learning
bias of the learning alogarithm is, in order to determine
what the best sub features are. Which means it's actually
worried about the problem of learning, itself. Which, I don't
know how to spell, apparently. [LAUGH] But in the process,
it's much much slower. Because every time it tries to look
at a particular subset, a candidate subset, it has to run
the learning algorithm. Imagine this learning algorithm is something like neural
network learning. This could take thousands
and thousands of iterations, you might
have to do cross validation, there's all kinds of things you
might have to do before you even get to look at
the next thing and and get a score. And so wrapping
makes a lot more sense because it takes into account the learning
problem and im more importantly the learning bias or
the inductive bias of the learning algorithm. But, it's going to
take a very, very long time to do it
while filtering tends to go pretty well. You buy that?
>> Yeah. That makes sense.
>> Okay. So I'm going to ask you a question
before we, sort of move on. Can you think
of any algorithms that we've looked at in the,
the last mini course, on supervised learning? It basically
was already doing filtering.
>> So, it's not quite the same,
because that's supervised, and now we're talking
about unsupervised. But we did look at
some algorithms that explicitly decided which features to
include, and which ones not. I'm thinking
of decision trees, maybe. And, I think boosting
kind of has a little bit of this depending on what the weak learner set is.
>> Right, that's true. I mean, we, the problem with, boosting is
that it's sort of not. It's not picking the features as much as
it's picking examples. But certainly with decision trees, you're exactly right.
Decision trees are in it's own way a kind of filtering algorithm.
So, this might not be obvious, and maybe I could have been
clearer about it, you get these features and I think you actually
asked me this question. But you get these features, but you do
know what the labels are if there's a supervised learner built it.
If you're going to have a learner at the end of the day,
you, it's not considered cheating in the filtering case. To look inside
the learner, but its not consider cheating to understand
what the labels are so you can take advantage
of the actual labels of your examples to do
your filtering. So in fact if you take the main
part of the decision trees which is the information
gain thats actually a way of doing filtering on the
features. So the criterion is information gain. Find me
the features that provide you with the most information given
the class label and that gets exactly the subset.
>> Cool. Now I don't, I don't quite see how to iterate that
though. So I can see how you can get the first feature that way,
then are we talking after that we're
going to select features that. Add information
above and beyond what we've already gotten
out of the other features we've selected?
>> Sure. So in fact, imagine that
my search algorithm here is actual decision trees.
So I take a bunch of features. I take a bunch of labeled data. I run
my decisino tree algorithim. It picks a subset of the features. Or maybe
I do pruning or cross. Whatever.
Assisted arbitrarty search algorithm. I just drew
a box here. And then what I do is I take all the
features that were used by the decision And I pass that to my learner.
>> Hm.
>> Now the learner is a decision tree learner. I presume
we get back the same decision tree. But maybe that's a
way of picking a subset of features that are useful for,
for example a new network or perceptron or KNN. In which case,
I don't quite see how to do the fed, the filtering.
>> Well, you run a decision tree algorithm here. [CROSSTALK]
>> Oh.
>> That gives you the set of
features that the decision tree thinks is important.
>> Oh.
>> And you return that set of features. Basically, the entire, not the
tree, but you flatten the tree and then just turn that into a
set of features. So imagine, for example, that we actually put inside this
box a decision-tree learner. That uses the set of data as input with all
of its features and all of the labels
that it knows about. It builds a decision tree
which gives you typically a subset, well in fact
by definition, gives you a subset of all the
features. And then the features that come out of
the decision tree are passed on to another learned
like for a example a perceptron or a nueral
network or even something like K and N. [UNKNOWN]
>> It always comes back to K and N.
>> Everything comes back to K and N. [LAUGH]
>> So let me make sure i understand we
run a decisoin tree learner but we dont want to
use what it actually determined? Instead, we say let's
just look at all the things that got split
on. And the union of all those now become
features to hand off to some other learning algorithm.
>> Right.
>> But, why would we want to do that
if we already trained up the decision tree?
>> Because maybe we're worried that the decision tree
doesn't do as good a job as you would
like. On noisy data for example. Or you're just
going to run the decision tree to some depth. Or,
even, what you want to do is, you're going to
run the decision tree until it actually overfits. And
now you know all the features that you could
use, and you pass that on to some other
learner, which has a different bias. So basically, you
use the inductive bias of the decision tree to
choose features, but then you use the inductive bias
of your other learner in order to do learning. Neat.
>> Right, and if you think about the
big difference between for example KNN and decision trees,
we know that KNN suffers from the curse of
dimensionality because it doesn't know which features are important.
So this, and but the decisions trees are very good at figuring out
which features are important, at least for predicting the label. And so you
can ask you're decision tree to give some hint to KNN which has
other nice things going for it, which
features it should actually pay attention to.
>> Cool.
>> Alright so there you go.